[Musique]
bonsoir le début d'une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 bienvenue
dans ce journal du lundi 18 janvier
voici les titres la vaccination
s'élargit dès aujourd'hui aux personnes
de plus de 75 ans est également plus de
65 ans présentant des comorbidités pour
ce faire neuf centres sont désormais
ouverts dans le département comme au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et à saint germain en laye et d'autres
devraient suivre et des communes ont
déjà fait part de leur disponibilité
c'est le cas de coignard dont le maire
didier fischer est notre invité il est
effectif depuis samedi le couvre feu
débute dorénavant à 18h dans l'ensemble
de la france et ce pour deux semaines
minimum ce week-end les yvelinois ont
adapté leur journée les commerces ont dû
fermer plus tôt exemple dans un centre
commercial aux clayes sous bois
et puis cette ligne de tramway doit
relier saint cyr l'école à saint germain
en laye en 30 minutes le thé 13 a pris
du retard en raison de la crise
sanitaire à la mise en service est
reportée à la mi 2022 samedi la
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse visite est la première
rame de la ligne dans un site de
maintenance était à versailles à suivre
également dans ce journal les yvelines
recouvert d'un manteau blanc pendant
quelques heures de la neige est tombée
samedi et ce qui a fait en premier lieu
le bonheur des enfants mais pour débuter
ce journal le but de cette opération
justement est de faire le bonheur des
enfants et plus précisément d'améliorer
leur vie quotidienne au sein de
l'hôpital mais aussi celle des
adolescents et des jeunes adultes
hospitalisés la 32e édition des pièces
jaunes est lancé jusqu'au 5 février pour
l'occasion la première dame brigitte
macron était à bullion aujourd'hui est
la présidente de l'opération s'est rendu
dans l'hôpital de pédiatrie et de
rééducation en compagnie du parrain des
pièces jaunes c'est le sélectionneur de
l'équipe de france de football et didier
deschamps épidémie oblige les pièces
jaunes seront à cette année et
digitalisées possibilité d'envoyer un
chèque mais aussi de faire un don de 5
euro par sms ou un don en ligne des
flashcodes seront également à retrouver
chez les commerçants partenaires
elle la stratégie de vaccination
poursuit son calendrier depuis
aujourd'hui ce sont les personnes de
plus de 75 ans et vivant à domicile qui
peuvent recevoir la première dose du
vaccin et neuf centres ont ouvert leurs
portes dans le département c'est le cas
notamment à saint germain en laye et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mélanie poker
et justine brasier après les dépistages
temps des vaccins le vélodrome national
de saint quentin en évier mais depuis ce
lundi 18 janvier un centre de
vaccination une date très attendue à
l'âge qu'on a un mois j'ai 86 gens et je
voudrais vivre encore quelques années
alors autant le faire par un autre
médecin qui a fait le nécessaire et bon
bah on a l'âge on vient pour vivre un
peu plus longtemps
dr ils m'ont conseillé de le faire
j'étais pas le vaccin sans problème 845
doses sont destinées aux personnes de
plus de 75 ans pour la première semaine
quand on rentre ici on est pris en
charge ces quasi militaire c'est c'est
avec une assistance médicale
d'organisation voilà tout tout tout est
prêt et se prépare pour pour ce moment à
saint germes en laisse et un centre
social et culturel qui est transformée
dans ce site intercommunal 600 personnes
seront vaccinées par semaine près de
40000 habitants ont plus de 75 ans et
quinze prochains jours vont être
constants à 6 ans et j'espère qu'on va
pouvoir monter et accroître la cadence
il faudrait qu'on dépasse en tout cas
ici mille personnes par semaine
a bien évidemment largement la la
capacité après on va essayer de
développer de nouveaux centres sur ça
trouve il est sur château et ça ça
dépend aussi de l'approvisionnement en
vaccins et de la décision du préfet et
les maires et les intercours ont des
moyens que parfois l'état a du mal à
réunir et donc il est tout à fait normal
d'être aux côtés de l'état pour assurer
cette fonction sanitaires
huit autres centres sont ouverts dans le
département ce lundi trois autres villes
pourraient accueillir des séances de
vaccination
prochaine étape du calendrier fin
février début mars pour les personnes
âgées de 65 à 74 ans le 9 centres de
vaccination donc déjà ouvert dans les
yvelines et vous l'avez vu trois vont
suivre dès la semaine prochaine à
sartrouville saint cyr l'école et les
mais nulle d'autres communes aussi se
sont portées candidates pour accueillir
des centres de vaccination c'est le cas
de la commune de coignières dont le
maire didier fischer est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir
alors le 9 janvier dernier vous avez
envoyé un courrier à la rs ile-de-france
l' agence régionale de santé avec en
copie le préfet des yvelines pour faire
part de la disponibilité de coignières à
accueillir un centre de vaccination pour
quoi faire cette démarche
bah parce que tout simplement je pense
que c'est nécessaire aujourd'hui les
grands centres de vaccination ne seront
pas à mon avis suffisant dans les
semaines voire dans les mois qui
viennent je pense qu'il faut aussi des
centres de proximité et c'est dans cette
dynamique là que s'inscrit en effet
coignières il faut penser que les
personnes les plus âgées les personnes
les plus précaires notamment nous ne se
déplaceront peut-être pas aussi
facilement que cela et il est nécessaire
à mon sens d'avoir à proximité donc des
centres au site vaccination et c'est la
demande que nous faisons la demande de
coignières et va dans ce sens là est ce
que dans la commune de coignières il ya
aujourd'hui des coignard rien justement
qui sont éligibles aux vaccins on
rappelle que depuis aujourd'hui la
vaccination est ouverte aux plus de 75
ans également bien sûr bien sûr on a on
a autour de 350 à 400 personnes qui sont
éligibles en effet à ce vaccin est dès
aujourd'hui d'une certaine façon est
évidemment ne passera pas
nos 300 400 personnes même je dirais
dans l'est dans les quelques jours qui
viennent je pense que ça sera
probablement sur plusieurs mois
malheureusement puisque le problème
actuel et ont tout le monde s'en rend
compte
c'est la disponibilité en doses de
vaccins dans un sens effectivement 20000
au rendez-vous qui sont d'ores et déjà
pris dans les yvelines mais qui vont
s'étaler sur plusieurs semaines
est ce que la commune de quoi bien
dispose aujourd'hui des infrastructures
et aussi des moyens pour organiser un
tel centre de vaccination pas bien sûr
bien sûr on a une grande salle notamment
notre salle des fêtes là les salons
saint-exupéry par exemple qui peuvent
être utilisés là aucun aucun souci on a
aussi bien entendu nos structures
médicales qui sont prêtes à agir 1 je
pense à nos deux pharmacies je pense à
notre centre médical où médecins et
infirmiers infirmières sont prêtes à se
mobiliser j'ai plus de 10 personnes
aujourd'hui prêts à se mobiliser pour
organiser ce type de vaccination non ça
ne pose aucun problème j'ai même des
volontaires des des infirmiers
infirmières à la retraite qui se disent
disposés à nous aider donc vous voyez on
peut très facilement dans les semaines
qui viennent organiser un centre de
proximité sur panne hier c'est ce que
vous dites
effectivement dans ce courrier vous avez
d'ores et déjà pris attache avec les
professionnels de santé de la commune
ça a été notre première démarche il
fallait savoir qu'elle veut dire si on
avait des bras à disposition et
effectivement je dirais moi pour moi ça
ne posait aucun problème je pensais que
effectivement ces personnes allaient se
mobilisent et elles ont répondu présent
et je les ans et je les en remercie bien
entendu nous sommes allés dire dans les
starting blocks il suffit que l'état
nous dise ok on y va eh bien à
coignières epr effectivement organiser
ce centre de vaccination de proximité
on a tout le matériel qu'il faut à
disposition on peut organiser des box on
peut faire des des salons plus intimes
enfin bon voyez on
peut très facilement mettre cela en
place à coignières en quelques heures
une journée par exemple ça pourrait
offrir une journée
on rappelle que le courrier a été
transmis le 9 janvier ce qu'aujourd'hui
lundi 18 janvier vous avez eu un retour
des services de l'état je n'ai pas eu de
retour des services et l'état à l'heure
actuelle j'ai des retours en fait des
médecins des infirmiers des pharmaciens
de poignard qui sont prêts à participer
à l'opération mais j'ai pas encore eu de
retour de l'état alors neuf centres sont
déjà ouverts dans les yvelines on a vu
que trois centrales et ouvrir ouvrir
prochainement dès la semaine prochaine
vous allez voir les différentes villes
s'afficher ça c'est pour donc les villes
qui ont déjà des centres de vaccination
vont s'afficher également les trois
prochaines qui vont accueillir un centre
encore faut-il vous disiez tout à
l'heure didier fischer des doses de
vaccin car les files d'attentes
s'allongent plusieurs élus d'ailleurs
alerte sur les pénurie de vaccins on
sait que cette semaine par exemple ce
sont 140 milles à 12 ans moins de ce qui
était prévu pour le vaccin un finder la
biotech qui seront livrées en france
dans le même temps olivier verrey on dit
que la stratégie suit son cours et que
l'organisation fonctionne le ministre de
la santé a tenté de rassurer aujourd'hui
votre regard sur le sujet ce que vous
êtes inquiet que les choses n'aillent
pas aussi vite que par exemple nos
voisins allemands ou italiens
on peut on peut être légitimement
inquiet mais bon je pense que bon on a
un certain nombre de doses je crois
qu'on a un million trois cent mille
doses de vaccin donc on peut faire les
premiers jours d'autres vaccins vont je
pense être produit même si feiler j'ai
vu avait ralenti ces chaînes pour les
adapter à une production supérieure
je pense que assez rapidement devrait
monter en puissance enfants tous les cas
je l'espère mais moi je voudrais dire à
propos du centre de proximité nous
éloigner on ne s'inscrit pas en
concurrence par exemple avec ce qui se
fait au vélodrome au contraire on vient
s'inscrire en complémentarité
parce qu'on sait très bien que ces
grands centres ne toucheront pas tout le
monde
il faut déplacer les personnes c'est
compliqué souvent on ne touchera pas
tout le monde donc c'est par la
proximité je pense qu'on réussira cette
vaccination de masse et d'ailleurs je
dirais la médecine de ville
pourra très vite quand on aura d'autres
vaccins je pense que avec pfizer s'est
un petit peu compliqué mais astrazeneca
par exemple on pourra plus facilement à
mon sens vacciné vacciner en proximité
voire vacciner même dans les cabinets
médicaux 1
c'est pour cela moi je ne suis pas
pessimiste 1 d'une manière générale je
suis plutôt d'un naturel optimiste je
pense qu'on réussira cette cette épreuve
maintenant on espère tous le cas on
espère tous que sly vide mais on sait
très bien que toute façon cette phase de
vaccination sera longue
on a bien compris les cinq phases
proposée par l'état et ce n'est que dans
la cinquième phase qu on vaccinera je
dirais pratiquement l'ensemble de la
population c'est-à-dire les 18 les 18 50
ans ce qu'il faut donner aujourd'hui un
rôle plus prépondérant peut-être aux
élus de la même manière qu'ils ont eu à
le faire avec les masques sur cette
vaccination
par exemple certains élus demandent la
possibilité d'acheter directement les
doses de vaccin est ce que ce pourrait
être une possibilité c'est une
possibilité moi je demande pas aller
jusque là mais ça pourrait être une
possibilité de toute façon nous élus
locaux on connaît bien notre terrain
connaît bien notre population
on a des capacités à agir localement je
crois que l'état aurait tort de se
priver de ses capacités une dernière
question d'idées fischer quand vous
serez éligible à la vaccination est ce
que vous même vous ferai vacciner
bien sûr bien sûr je me ferai vacciner
est bon mais je serai pas éligible tout
de suite tout de suite je vais arriver
dans la troisième ou la quatrième la
quatrième vague mais bien sûr je me
ferai vacciner dès que je pourrais me
faire vacciner je me ferai vacciner
merci didier fischer d'avoir été avec
nous d'après merci à vous je rappelle le
maire de coignières est également élu et
vice président de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines elle les
derniers chiffres de l'épidémie du colis
de 19 à présent dans les yvelines vous
le voyez à part pour le taux d'incidence
est à dire le nombre de personnes
contaminées pour 100000 habitants les
autres données sont à la baisse dans les
yvelines sur une semaine les autres
données donc sont à la baisse sa baisse
légèrement vous le voyez par exemple
pour le taux de test positif côté
hôpitaux à une semaine on dénombre
- d'hospitalisation et moins de
personnes en réanimation également
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
1152 personnes sont décédées du
coronavirus dans les hôpitaux du
département et des derniers chiffres à
la baisse mais une situation épidémique
qui reste tout de même tendu c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement a décidé est
d'élargir le couvre-feu dès 18h à
l'ensemble de la france samedi
les premières pour la première journée
de cette sous cette mesure les i bleues
ont dû bousculer leurs habitudes et les
commerces plier boutique plutôt
reportage aux clayes-sous-bois avec
pierre hugot weber et bixente pierre
hugot reiber pardon et bixente mariens
antiste est bonne depuis samedi soir
impossible de faire ses courses passé 18
heures avec l'avancement du couvre feu
sur l'ensemble du territoire les
commerçants sont contraints de s'adapter
l'objectif est maintenant simple restez
ouvert le plus longtemps possible
il a fallu changer les horaires
d'ouverture nous avons normalement une
amplitude de 10 heures à 20 heures le
samedi et on ouvre à 11 heures la
semaine est donc là on a avancé notre
ouverture à 9 heures et nous fermons à
18 heures désormais les boutiques compte
sur l'heure du déjeuner pour rattraper
le manque à gagner en soirée un
changement forcé qui ne compensera pas
les baisses de fréquentation les
boutiques
elle voit surtout le manque de chiffre
d'affaires parce que le créneau horaire
18 20 heures est un créneau horaire qui
effectivement fort donc entre 20 et 40%
de la journée dans quelle voie avant
tout la perte de chiffre d'affaires mais
il faut faire seulement deux heures de
décalage qui rendent pourtant difficile
les sortir en magasin entre le travail
les activités et la famille pas le choix
il faut changer ses habitudes
globalement oui ça va sûrement ça va
être plus dur c'est sûr bon je dirais
dans la semaine quand on travaille ça va
pas changer grand chose mais
effectivement pour faire ses courses
comme il s'est un peu plus tendue quoi
ça nous oblige à légèrement avancer nos
habitudes en hiver pour connaître c'est
pas trop contraignant
c'est juste une question d'organisation
alors que les soldes commencent mercredi
prochain les commerçants craignent que
le couvre-feu à 18 heures entraîne une
nouvelle fois une baisse de
fréquentation dans les magasins dans le
reste de l'actualité la visite de nadia
est dans les yvelines la ministre
déléguée chargée de la ville s'est rendu
cet après midi à poissy commune qui
sollicitent le label des sites éducative
il est attribué par le gouvernement il
va mobiliser 17 millions d'euros pour 40
nouvelles villes labellisées l'objectif
accompagner chaque enfant dans son
parcours éducatif de la petite enfance
jusqu'à l'insertion professionnelle un
accompagnement qui se fera de manière
personnalisée au programme du
déplacement visite du fab lab de poissy
du collège des à grandchamp avant la
tenue d'une réunion en mairie et nous
reviendrons sur cette visite dans notre
journal de demain mardi un nouvel outil
pour le tribunal judiciaire de
versailles le bracelet anti
rapprochement c'est un système qui
permet la géolocalisation d'une victime
de violences conjugales et de son
agresseur pour une meilleure protection
rappelez vous c'était l'une des mesures
du grenelle des violences conjugales qui
s'était tenu il ya un an
vendredi au tribunal de versailles les
différents acteurs de la lutte contre
les violences se sont réunis pour signer
un protocole de mise en oeuvre du
bracelet anti rapprochement les propos
recueillis par astrid bergère lorsque le
dispositif lui est octroyée à la victime
il ya autour d'elle une zone de
protection au sein de laquelle lorsque
le mis-en-cause rentrer le dispositif se
déclenche une alarme se déclenche donc
bien
avant que la victime ne voit son
potentiel agresseurs donc on est sur une
augmentation extrêmement importante de
la protection et cette mesure du
bracelet antibes rapprochement peut être
prononcée au moment de la condamnation
ou par le juge d'application des peines
en 2020 les gardes à vue pour des
raisons de violences intrafamiliales ont
augmenté de 59% dans les yvelines
ils se disent favorables à la
légalisation du cannabis 36 maires
franciliens et de l'oise ont été
questionnés sur le sujet par nos
confrères du parisien
c est lui administre des communes
situées en zones de sécurité
prioritaires 50% des édiles interrogées
se disent donc favorable à cette mesure
parmi eux des élus des yvelines le maire
génération de trappes ali rabais
estiment que la répression est
contre-productive comme pour la
prohibition de l que de l'alcool dans
les années 20 aux états unis et puis
raphaël cognait également le maire et
les républicains et de mantes la jolie a
longtemps était contre mais son
expérience à la tête de la ville lui a
fait changer d'avis pour lui arrêter le
trafic uniquement de manière policière
et judiciaire paraît utopique est parmi
les personnes interrogées les autres
élus interrogés 22 % sont contre mais
d'autres ne se prononce pas sur la
question
transports la région ile-de-france
mobilité ont présenté samedi la nouvelle
rame du thé 13 le tramway devrait relier
saint cyr l'école à saint germain en
laye en 2022 l'année prochaine donc car
le chantier a pris du retard les
explications d'eléonore sinoquet et
d'astrid bergère à l'été 2022 c'est
l'objectif de la mise en service de la
ligne 13 du tramway en cours de
construction dans les yvelines
un projet de longue date qui a pris six
mois de retard à cause de la crise
sanitaire
il reliera les communes de saint cyr
l'école et saint germain en laye en 30
minutes
la première rame est arrivé sur le site
de maintenance de versailles
ce samedi se trame à tout le confort
avec des prises usb la vidéoprotection
l'ensemble des éléments et il est 100%
accessible donc c'est vraiment un
tramway qui apportera une qualité et un
confort pour les usagers
au quotidien d'une longueur de 42 mètres
les rames seront également dotés de la
climatisation
dix autres rames seront livrés d'ici
l'été prochain chacune pourra contenir
250 et en voyageur avec 95 places
assises nous tenions à ce que les
yvelines et leur tramway
pourquoi parce que les tramways c'est la
transition écologique c'est la
possibilité de se déplacer à l'intérieur
des yvelines sans prendre sa voiture et
aujourd'hui cette possibilité elle n'est
quasiment pas possible sauf en bus avec
des temps de trajet qui sont extrêmement
longs donc là on va faire en une
demi-heure sans cire saint germain en
laye et puis dans la phase 2 on ira
jusqu à poissy et achève donc ça veut
dire quoi c'est à dire qu'on va pouvoir
enfin traverser les yvelines
sans prendre sa voiture la région
ile-de-france estime entre 20000 pour le
premier tronçon et jusqu'à 40 mille
voyageurs
lorsque l'ensemble de la ligne 13 sera
en service un retard sur les chantiers
la crise sanitaire a aussi contraint à
des événements à se réinventer le salon
de l'étudiant ile de france se tiendra
cette année en 100% virtuel il était
programmé à la base au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines ce
sera finalement en ligne du 21 au 23
janvier le rendez vous s'adresse aux
lycéens souhaitant s'informer sur leur
orientation post-bac et sur la
plateforme parcours super aussi aux
étudiants de bac + 1 à bac + 3 au
programme découverte de formation chat
en live chat en live avec des
responsables d'établissements pour y
participer il faut créer un compte
visiteurs c'est simple et rapide via le
lien qui s'affiche rendez vous ce jeudi
à partir de 9 heures allez on termine ce
journal avec un peu plus de légèreté de
la neige est tombée sur le département
des yvelines samedi plus de 5 cm
localement ont recouvert le temps d'une
après midi les routes et les plaines de
quoi ravir les enfants mais pas que
regardez ce sujet d'astrid bergère
pierre hugot reiber aux commentaires un
joli manteau blanc a recouvert saint
quentin en yvelines vers 10 heures les
premiers flocons ont commencé à tomber
rapidement déneigement et salage ont eu
lieu ça se passe plutôt bien
on a été un peu surpris au départ mais
dans l'ensemble tout s'est bien passé ça
glisse par endroits mais bon ça c'est
normal
et donc voilà on fait refaire certaines
zones qui ont été qui ont été traitées
mais qui entre temps par manque de
brassage d'ailleurs pendant que de deux
passages de voitures ben voilà ça ça se
recouvrent et dont il faut refaire
passer des services mais dans l'ensemble
tout et tout est bien dans l'après-midi
le rôle des patrouilleurs est de
vérifier les conditions climatiques afin
de savoir si d'autres passages sont
nécessaires mais les plus heureux ce
sont sûrement les enfants partout dans
les rues on voit luge traîneaux et après
ski ils sont tous sortis de chez eux
pour des raisons bien précises et les
enfants n'ont qu'un seul espoir
les douze déneigeuses ont été mobilisés
le temps de cet épisode la neige
elle s'est arrêtée de tomber vers 15h30
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant
l'actualité sportive dans le département
des yvelines star retrouvés dont le
cetud sport présentée par michael et
demi d'euros et belle soirée à tous avec
tv 78
[Musique]